- Rudy Giuliani is suspended
from the practice of law indefinitely.
He hasn't been disbarred yet,
but that may be coming.
The New York Bar has found
that Rudy Giuliani has violated
many of his ethical
obligations as a lawyer,
especially with respect to being truthful
and honest in front of tribunals.
They have found that there
is incontrovertible evidence
that he in fact lied
to countless numbers of
courts and individuals
with respect to the 2020 election.
As we've talked about
a lot on this channel,
lawyers have to be truthful.
They cannot lie in furtherance
of their client's aims.
And the New York courts
found that Rudy lied
with respect to mail-in
ballots in Pennsylvania
and lied about a lot of the things
that were happening in Georgia.
Rudy argued that this violates
his First Amendment rights,
but that generally doesn't work
when you're talking
about ethical violations
with respect to a profession.
In this case, the profession
of practicing law.
This is of course is highly unusual,
but the magnitude of the
lies that Rudy was telling
in front of lots of different courts
is also extremely unusual.
So he is suspended indefinitely,
pending further investigation.
So we will definitely see Rudy in court
to see if he is disbarred.